with a background in pro skateboarding
Jason Lee made an unexpected mark in
Hollywood when he starred as the comedic
antihero Brodie Bruce in 1995's kevin
smith directed cult hits mall rounds all
right guys you have your mission go
forth
lead then quickly rose through the ranks
appearing in chasing amy dogma and Jay &
Silent Bob strike back then from the
indie film world to mainstream TV Lee's
most prominent role came with NBC's
comedy hit my name is pearl which
garnered him multiple award nominations
a multi-faceted artist Lee maintained an
actively creative lifestyle after the
show went off the air here's a closer
look to what he's been up to since he's
shaved off Earl's moustache behind the
camera in 2003 Lee directed Beck's
lonesome tears music video and it
appears the project gave him the freedom
to pursue a career behind the camera
according to Lee the Beck video led to
the creation of his 2006 short film the
white door and his partnership with Beck
led to his helming multiple music videos
for American folk rock band Midlake
religion gets personal Lee married his
first wife actress photographer Carmen
Llewellyn in 1995 throughout their
relationship Lee did his best to keep
his wife involved with him in the Church
of Scientology but the couple divorced
six years later according to a Gawker
op-ed from Llewelyn the final straw was
Lee's Scientology practice then in 2001
Lee was linked to actress Beth Riesgraf
in 2003 their son pilot inspector was
born and soon the couple became engaged
ultimately the two never tied the knot
and it was speculated that Scientology
may have been the culprit behind their
breakup in 2007 the Chipmunks dynasty in
2007 we gave a live-action human face to
Dave Seville the adoptive father to the
three Rodin's heroes and Alvin and the
Chipmunks Lee reprised the role in the
accompanying video game as well
according to box office mojo the film
earned roughly 361 million dollars
worldwide and prompted three sequels
2009's
Alvin and the Chipmunks the Squeakquel
2011's Alvin and the Chipmunks
shipwrecked and 2015's Alvin and the
Chipmunks the
chip
Jason Lee voice actor a year before he
started filming My Name Is Earl Lee
appeared as the villainous syndrome in
Disney's The Incredibles
he was the first time the actor flexed
his voiceover chops and it was a
slam-dunk superhero
Leah since reprised his role in The
Incredibles video game
this short film Jack Jack Attack and the
Disney infinity video game franchise his
voice has also been regularly featured
in the animated series we bare bears
where he plays a Bigfoot named Charlie
golly would you just look at this place
rustic charming a slick headband by the
way a less than triumphant return Lee
had made a name for himself playing
offbeat characters but in 2010 the actor
delved into procedurals with TNT's
short-lived cop drama Memphis beat the
show however wouldn't live to see a
third season leave then quickly moved
back to NBC for a recurring role in up
all night in 2011 he appeared in only
seven episodes of the show which went on
hiatus halfway into season two before
being officially canceled by the network
then in 2015 Mallrats director Kevin
Smith announced that a sequel to his
cult hit would finally see the light of
day tweeting 20 years in the making
113 pages full of old friends and new
jokes Lee was set to reprise his role in
Smith's new Mallrats movie but getting
the rights from Universal proved to be
an epic challenge instead Smith retooled
the project for television and while it
seemed that Brody would finally get his
comeback cinema blend reported no
network showed interest in the project
staying true to his roots Lee retired
from pro skateboarding in 95 but back in
92 he and fellow pro skateboarder crisp
Astra's had created their own skate
brand stereo skateboards after over a
decade off the rails Lee returned to
skating and relaunched the company with
pastoris in 2003 combining their love
for record collecting and privation alas
I movie making stereo has sent stood out
from the pack with its unique brand
aesthetic and quality boards moving out
of Hollywood
we practice Scientology for more than
two decades but in 2016 he revealed that
he and his second wife
Geron Lee had left Scientology
altogether the break occurred around the
same time the couple moved to Denton
Texas with their three children Lee told
the den tonight we're not here to buy up
or change or take over Denton put some
kind of personal stamp on it
we're just here like anyone else he
wants to be a part of Benton's very cool
creative community and to be involved
and perhaps help where we can
ever since Lee is taken on a variety of
off-screen endeavors and it seems the
skateboarder actor/director photographer
has found fulfillment in shifting his
focus from Hollywood's glitz and glam to
doing what he really loves
[Music]